did you hear about people's magazine
did you just say did i hear about people
did you not watch et canada
no
wrong answer you are grounded this is it
no yes of course we heard about it you
are people's sexiest tick-tock star what
does that feel like
feels good you know i don't think i'm
the sexiest
that's a good thing to say but yeah
yeah feels good
i mean your fans voted five million
times
they really got in there what do you
have to say to your fans for this
because that's really incredible
yeah
like honestly i'm really realizing
lately that it's my team and my fans
that are getting me here it is me too
but like it's really a team effort you
know what i mean
yeah no for sure it is it takes i mean
you have some pretty incredible fans
like ever since you came across my tick
tock and i spoke to you once
they've sort of adopted me they're a
very powerful group of people
yeah no i know eh
like they're helping like my family
start up stuff my friends so it's it's
like the whole community is coming up
it's nice that's really special so were
you shocked when you heard that you were
voted tick tock's you know sexy star and
where were you when you heard and how
did it all come about
um so i was
i don't remember where i was now geez um
i think i was at my grandma's and i was
like i found out about it i was like oh
my gosh no freaking way
i beat noah back because noah black's a
big deal has a good fan base and i was
like
beauty i used to
yeah
that's incredible now um i imagine once
that happened a lot of things started to
snowball what exciting things have
happened since that uh i guess since
that win
um
i went to la that was sweet
i walked a red carpet i met like addison
ray and a bunch of celebrities
um
i think i'm going back to paris in
january
and yeah just like more exposure like
you know like i'm starting to get out in
that celebrity world and it's pretty
cool i could see like yeah dreams
becoming a reality that's cool so great
so um
where would you like to see this go i
know the last time we talked modeling
was still something that you were
incredibly interested in are you still
really interested in modeling
yeah i want to be like a really i want
to be like good model like i'm greek
right
so i want to be like those greek statues
like local rep that's my goal
and then hopefully
star in like some big movie or something
one day
yeah so what are you doing to get
yourself prepped for the acting thing
are you doing acting classes are your
agents working like what's happening
yes so we're doing acting classes right
now i'm loving it right now it's like
putting me in this new world i get to
act like a different person like i get
to be this guy xavier and he really
wants to get this girl so i gotta like
work hard for this girl it's pretty cool
and
yeah that's what i'm doing i'm preparing
i'm focusing on my mental health lately
like really hardcore
you know
and
yeah
so when you say focusing on your mental
health i mean a lot of things happen
really quickly for you
um and then
you just decided that it was time to
also take care of you explain a little
bit about that
just like
i'm always out i always have to be with
friends or i always have to be part like
doing something and now it's like really
taking a toll on me so
it's time to
you know like figure out who will really
is and who he wants to be and start
focusing on me it's going to be tough
but it is what it is i have to do it now
right
no you do that's something you have to
keep in check all the way along right
it's it's you don't want to get that to
be a runaway train that's for sure um we
know how good you're at at creating tick
tocks but now do you feel a little more
pressure after being voted people's
sexiest tick-tocker
yeah honestly ever since i've been yeah
ever since i've been famous
it's a little more pressure because it's
like
like i always feel like people are
watching me i gotta i don't want to put
out content that isn't like really good
so
you know that's the only thing but
i'm getting over it it's like it's just
i look at it as just the stepping stones
like every celebrity has to go through
that feeling and then if you get through
that feeling you a new light you know
it's like
it's true
absolutely so right now um who do you
love watching on tick tock who are you
who are who's on your feet all the time
uh
there's
vinnie hacker big he's
he's i think he's younger than me he's
like
19 but he's like
very good looking guy knows what he's
doing like doing really good i like that
kid um
trying to think who else break i don't
really like go through tick-tock too
much though and i should because then i
can find trends
canada you love you love looking at et
canada and cheryl hickey's page
honestly i do cheryl hickey you're funny
you're i like watching your song
okay good one good one you're saved
you're saved
um you've had some amazing gigs come up
though like you're working with iconic
brands like the bay
and although
um what does it feel to be attached to
brands that people just know and love so
much
oh it feels so good and it feels so sick
that like i was on all those like
uh
billboard yeah
walking through the mall i've always
wanted to kind of like take a picture
like and just be like yo it's me on the
billboard a lot of people definitely
should you definitely should i've seen
over the last couple of days you've been
hanging out with dad back working
together um how important is it for you
to just have those moments too not the
los angeles
not the billboard ads but being with
your dad in the truck
hanging out working
i know i
those moments are so special like i say
i like them more than la and stuff
because honestly it does feel like just
more relaxing and
stuff the la life gives me a little bit
of anxiety but i still love it
but yeah but
no like
i really like work with my dad he keeps
my head like somewhere else we have
normal talks like who's gonna win
football and stuff it's not like trying
to be better than the next person so
yeah
those are just so good to do and like
yeah
yeah
and of course your fans want to know
because they sent me about well they
sent me a few hundred questions
are you dating are you single or can you
even answer it
i'm single
yeah
ready to mingle
okay amazing